well we suspected it might happen
because of the increasingly uncontrolled
spread of the delta variant and the
resurgence in covid 19 cases
and it is happening the cdc coming out
with new mass guidelines yesterday
we are going backwards the masks are
going back on
in many many places and seemingly
overnight i'm already seeing more masks
just walking around and yes
this is even for vaccinated
people we're going to look at the new
guidelines
and i am going to sort of couch it all
in saying
um the situation has not really
changed that dramatically for vaccinated
people
although it has changed and it's
important to understand the ways in
which it has
but this is continuing to increasingly
be
a virus that is being spread by
unvaccinated people
which is disproportionately seriously
affecting unvaccinated people
uh and that for now appears to be the
way it is going to continue but that
doesn't mean given what's going on
that vaccinated people shouldn't take
precautions in certain places so
let's look at the new cdc guidelines
updated
yesterday when you've been fully
vaccinated
okay if you are fully vaccinated you can
participate in many of the activities
that you did before the pandemic
to that maximize protection from the
delta variant and prevent possibly
spreading it to others
wear a mask indoors in public if you are
in an area
of substantial or high transmission that
is a major change
whereas before the position was if
you're vaccinated
you don't really need to wear a mask
anywhere the new guidelines are
if you're vaccinated but you're indoors
in public meaning not with five other
people whose vaccination status you know
but if you're in public indoors
and in an area of high transmission um
which you can look at at a county by
county level
substantial or high transmission the new
recommendation
is to wear a mask for me what does that
mean well that means
when i go to the grocery store the mask
is going back on
um it goes on to say the new guidelines
wearing a mask is most important if you
have a weakened immune system or if
because of your age or an underlying
medical condition
you are at increased risk for severe
disease or if someone in your household
has a weakened immune system
is at increased risk for severe disease
or is unvaccinated if this applies to
you
or your household you might choose to
wear a mask regardless of the level of
transmission in your area
you should continue to wear a mask where
required by laws
rules regulations or local guidance
so this is a significant
change and we are seeing the spike i
mean if you look at the u.s
case numbers you will see that starting
oh
i don't know right around june 22nd
about about a month ago after getting
down below 10
000 cases per day cases started to go up
up
up including even some 65 000 uh
case days now up to an average of about
57
000 cases per day now what's the hope
here
the hope is that much like we are
starting to see
in some other countries for example if
you look at the uk
which was essentially one of the hubs of
the delta variant
we have already apparently hit the peak
of cases in the uk
that the peak in the uk of delta
seems to have happened around july 22nd
and they are now down from about 46 000
cases a day
to about 32 000 that's a significant
reduction the hope is
that what is now a sort of leveling out
as you can
see over the last few days the cases
aren't continuing to increase in the us
they're sort of
flattening out the hope would be we are
now going to be
on the decline but we don't know if we
are and part of that depends of course
on taking precautions so let's not go
crazy one way or the other
i think there's a lot of hyperbole on
both sides here and i'm not
playing a both sides game the people
responsible for this
are overwhelmingly the unvaccinated
people and the people taking no
precautions
but the reactions have been sort of
extreme on both sides there's one side
that two months ago said the pandemic is
over
many of these people were never wearing
masks many of these people are still not
vaccinated and they're going back and
and to quote dr anthony fauci letting it
rip
that's an extreme reaction on one side
because it's clearly not over
on the other side are the people who are
seeing this and now saying
we are back to the pre-vaccine
uncontrolled spread
era the truth is that for the delta
variant
if you're vaccinated you're very well
protected
and that protection is bolstered by
people around you being vaccinated now
just like with the flu there are people
who are
vaccinated um who will
who are otherwise mostly healthy who
will get what's called the breakthrough
case
and they will end up hospitalized and a
few of them are going to die
and that's a terrible and tragic thing
but it's important to remember that that
also happens with the flu
and we that doesn't mean we ignore this
fact
but it also doesn't mean that we all of
a sudden believe there's no protection
and we're going back to the
pre-vaccine-covered era
the truth is that for the most part you
are quite well protected if you were
vaccinated you were really unlikely to
get very sick
you were really unlikely to die however
you could spread it you could spread it
to someone who is
in a more compromised position and
although that's the situation with the
delta variant
the more people remain unvaccinated and
the more the spread continues
the next variant could be more deadly
the next variant could be even more
transmissible and as we've said before
imagine if this had an
eight percent mortality rate or a ten
percent mortality rate if
i don't know that people are looking to
read about this type of stuff right now
that this i don't know people are
looking for this type of fiction
but i recently read lawrence wright's uh
pandemic novel
um i believe it's called the end of
october where
it's a very similar situation to the one
we have except it's like a 10
death rate instead of a 0.8 death rate
or whatever we believe the real
um infection fatality rate to be that is
a dramatically different situation
the more we don't get vaccinated and the
more this continues to spread
it increases the chances of such a
variant developing in the future so
these are the rules at this point in
time
um people asking me if i'm if i'm
canceling my upcoming travel
i'm not and the reason i'm not is this
situation
of different pops and spreads
particularly among the unvaccinated is
likely to continue for a couple of years
and so if i'm not willing to travel
now i probably would shouldn't travel
for years and i've made the decision in
speaking with
friends who are doctors and others that
right now based on when i got vaccinated
and based on this particular variant
and based on the fact that i'll be
wearing a mask everywhere that it's
recommended i don't see a particular
reason to cancel that trip now
um but a lot of the questions are where
are you going and
and what is your health status etc one
example
we're talking on the bonus show today
nevada or nevada
is going fully masked back on and people
are being advised to avoid las vegas the
level
level of uncontrolled spread in las
vegas is so high the case positivity
rate is so high
that that's a point where people are
being told just don't go there
uh and i don't plan to so that's uh
that's the situation there
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier
and more affordable way to do primary
care and they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on
your doctor will be available to you by
text phone and video chat it's not some
random doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50
off your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video